fio musical é cor que eu não eu odeio eu
acho que você sabe que você virou adulto
quando você não aguenta a parte da
música no filme musical Você tá gostando
do filme começa a música E você faz isso
aqui ó você tá assistindo a cena Ei
Steven o que acha de irmos ao refeitório
poderia ir agora mesmo Kevin Quando
vamos ao refeitório começou a parte da
música Então fiquei mesmo aborrecido a
gente começa a botar defeito no filme
como é que esse cara essa baleta se ele
não sabe nem a música que o carinha
cantar Aí do nada já sabe é a letra Aí
do nada Levanta a mesa dos esqueitista
eles começa a dançar aí os esqueitista
dançando nem conhece o cara do filme
estão dançando a música que os caras
estão cantando bolas aí levanta o grupo
dos nerds
Aí eu saio de medo Macacos me morder eu
fiquei mesmo aborrecido agora o nerd
sabe dançar break break não sabe dançar
nem capoeira